I think there there's a lot of impostor
syndrome that happens in acting I know
and and I used to feel that all the time
because you go from job to job to job to
job and every time you start a job I
think my biggest pressure that I would
have on myself is I just want the other
actors in this to think I'm a good actor
yeah I think I still you know I think
every actor still probably has that but
if you've been if you're going back to a
place repeatedly you lose that and you
just sort of I don't want to use the
word autopilot but you go into a a
comfort zone where you know the
character so well that you are not
second guessing any choice is and you're
just you're just doing and being which
is the perfect state to act in